- [Announcer] Middle Ground
is a social experiment
that brings humans with
opposing beliefs together.
Please see the humanity in
each participant and as always,
we encourage empathy.
- I am happy now in my teen years
but then what my adult
year is gonna be like?
So I'm neutral about the future.
Hit me with it, I got it.
Hit me with it.
(soft upbeat music)
- [Announcer] Step forward
if you agree with the prompt,
boys are stronger than girls.
- Well, physically like for
the most part in gender roles
and stuff like that, boys are
just supposed to be stronger.
That's just a thing that happens.
They work out at the gym and yeah,
girls certainly can work out
too if they want but again,
it's more common for boys.
- [Announcer] Can my
disagreers step forward?
- Who's one to say what
gender like, who's stronger?
It doesn't matter what gender you are.
It matters who you are.
It doesn't matter what you were born,
it matters what you wanna be.
- You could be referring
to strength in so many ways
like physically, emotionally,
where the strength in your body is placed.
Like it all just depends.
And there's just so many
factors that go into it.
- Like I play volleyball and sometimes
we play the boys teams and
we like, we've crushed them
a couple times and it
feels so good, you know?
So I wouldn't necessarily,
I don't agree with that.
- I think getting rid of like
these preconceived notions
that like boys go to gyms,
girls like stay at home like,
one of my best friends is a
girl and like she's stronger
than half the guys I know.
My name's Kolby, I'm in eighth grade
and I'm a middle school boy.
I do have like guy friends
but like when I would ask them
questions or like when I would
try to talk about emotion,
it was almost like shut down.
And I feel like I just have
like deeper connections
with like women around me than
a lot of the men that I do.
- [Narrator] I am old enough to date.
- Obviously more of like
figuring yourself out
comes in later years but I
feel like these relationships
really shape how you feel about
relationships in the future
and it's important to have them.
- Yeah and I mean, I think
that it begins to become
different when you get into
like the sexual aspects
of a relationship and dating.
I think that this age you don't
know enough about yourself
as a person at this age
to give consent correctly
and to understand like,
this is a powerful moment
and I think that like at age 12,
it can be kind of hard to grasp that.
- You guys can date,
I'm me, you're not me,
so I personally would never
date but you guys do your thing.
It's like, it's your jazz, not mine, so.
- I think there's just a lot more to life
before you have to slow down.
Like I wanna ride my bike
in the middle of the street
and then binge eat popsicles
and watch my favorite TV show
before I have to slow down
which I have seven more years
before I'm officially an adult
so I think I wanna experience
life before I stop all that.
- I think when we talk
about dating it's like,
we're going through so
much physiological change.
Our mental state is just
so fragile and like insane
at this age that like dating to me like,
the risk just outraged
reward and like Gen Zs,
all of our experiences
are getting moved up
by like five years.
I think I can hold out
like a few more years like
I don't think I need
to like rush anything.
- I think at this age we're
more prone to like getting upset
over a smaller thing than what
we would be when we're older.
And then I also think if
like someone at our age
is gonna date, it should
be something light and fun,
not anything serious.
- I feel like being dating is
more like emotionally focused
at our age.
And then being like
sexually active while dating
is like a whole other topic.
- Well, like both people
should be present and aware
and almost like constantly
aware of how they're feeling
with one another in
order for it to a safe,
healthy relationship.
- Well, I mean, either way,
if you were to date like,
even in the middle of like,
for example, middle school,
most of the time it wouldn't work out.
So there's no reason to like
purposely like do everything
you can to uphold it, either way you know
it's not really gonna work.
It's just a good experience
to start yourself
and prepare for the future.
- Hi, I'm Gordon, I'm in sixth grade
and I'm a middle school boy.
My favorite thing about
middle school is probably
just the fact that it's not
too young to be considered like
a basic school but it's
also not too high up
so you have too many
responsibilities at once
like student loans.
So yeah, it's very simple
and straight forward.
- [Announcer] I understand
what a woman's period is.
- Well, it's like a hormone
reaction that causes blood
to come out of, you know
where, that's essentially it.
It happens like maybe a
few times a month and yeah,
it's not very comfortable.
- It's like, once you start
it, they say it's supposed
to be irregular for the
first two years and mine is,
like one time I didn't
have it for 10 months.
And then I got it and it was for 13 days.
- Same, mine is for like four months.
- Oh my God.
- I think it's great that all
of you guys know what it is
but I have count list amount
of guy friends that well,
they just don't understand what it is.
They think, oh, you bleed for
like 10 seconds a day, right?
Yeah and I'm like, no,
that's not what happens.
- Same, it's so annoying.
- And I feel like my school,
especially with the pandemic,
like we skipped our
health unit in fifth grade
because of COVID and
it's just our teachers
when we went through sex ed this year,
my teacher didn't teach it really.
- Speaking of sex ed, there
are no government regulations
for what sex ed can be.
And you have these people in other places
where their only sex ed is like,
don't have sex until marriage
or else you'll get an STD and.
- I'm glad everyone knows
because it's such an important
thing in a woman's life.
And I think if it's not
taught then nobody's learning.
- You're right.
- [Announcer] I don't
like how my body looks.
- With me, it is about like
my weight and how I show up
in the world.
It's not something I talk to like anyone
except for my parents about it's like,
it's always a nagging thing,
always in the back of my head
every time I look in a mirror,
every time I talk to someone
with a body that I like
envy and I can't really go
to any of my male friends about it
because they will just like,
stop being so sensitive,
you look fine and it's like,
but I don't think that.
- I suffered a lot last year
just thinking about myself.
I counted calories all
the time, I still do it.
Sometimes when my anxiety
gets worse and then you know,
seventh grade hit and my
closest friend developed
an eating disorder and
we have a very similar
body structure.
Like I know that weight
is distributed differently
but it just doesn't
register well in my head.
'Cause then I'm like, well,
if you think you're fat,
then what am I?
This has been a big source
of part of my mental health issues.
I mean, I still don't
know how to deal with it
'cause I'm still trying
to figure myself out.
Hi, my name is Natalie.
I'm in seventh grade and
I'm a middle school girl.
I have friends who I know
they don't pressure me into it
but it's just like when they
go out wearing this like
Lululemon crop tops, I don't
wanna wear that kind of stuff.
You know, it definitely feeds
into my body image issues.
- I think it doesn't really
matter about like the looks,
I think it really matters
about like personality.
- Like I used to have
really bad body dysmorphia
and it's really hard
especially playing volleyball,
seeing everyone like
those small little shorts
and then being like, oh,
those legs look really nice.
Like, oh, I really want to look like that.
But then you know, it's been
hard but I've just grown
to realize that like I'm who
I am and I look like this
and you know, they look like
that and great, you know?
- I know for a lot of guys like my age,
like they're always working
out and stuff and for a while
I almost did that like, I would
like go to the gym every day
and stuff like that.
But then like kind of
noticed I would be tired,
I would have like more
extreme mood swings like
I was just like a less
enjoyable person to be around.
Like I think we don't talk about how like
men view themselves like
their bodies as much.
- Personally myself, I've
never even thought about this.
I just never really
thought about how I looked.
I had a pretty okay metabolism and yeah,
that's pretty much what
carried me and now we're here.
- I think it's just like,
yay, my body's here, cool.
Like I can run with
it, I can swim with it.
It wasn't with my body as
much as it was with hair
because my hair obviously
looked different from your hair.
So when I was younger, I
straightened my hair once
and everyone had straight
hair and I was just like,
I want hair straight hair.
I wanna look like her,
she has pretty hair.
My hair's all fluffy and dry.
Hers is nice and straight and pretty.
So it was just like that feeling of like
having to look like everybody else
but I think I've found the confidence now.
- You know, when I was in
second and third grade,
all the girls have
straight hair I was like,
oh my gosh, I want that straight hair.
And then all those girls were like,
Suhailah, I love your hair.
You know, like your hair is gorgeous.
And I was like, really?
And then I was just you know,
I started to actually appreciate my hair,
it's a part of like who I am
and that's a beautiful part of who I am.
And your hair is gorgeous, by the way.
- [Boy] You have really great hair.
- [Announcer] I feel like I understand
my sexual orientation.
- Well, I mean, there's
not really any room to it.
It's just you're straight or you're not,
in which case, if you're
not, it becomes complicated
but if you're straight,
it's pretty obvious.
- Fair, I'm gay and asexual.
Putting labels on things helps me so yeah,
that's how I identify at this point
and I am very confident in that.
And I mean, depending on where I am,
I'll be more out or less out.
I have to hide who I am because
I'm in fear for my safety.
I figured out it was
asexual a little later
just because sexual
attraction becomes something
that people increasingly begin to have.
I never had 'em,
that's how I identify at this
point in time and I mean,
sexuality is obviously like
a fluctuating spectrum.
Hi, I'm Owen, I'm in eighth grade
and I'm a middle school boy.
Coming out in my school, it
was definitely an experience.
I received tremendous
support from the small
but strong LGBTQ plus
community within my school.
It made me feel amazing about who I was
and that I was able to meet
people who were like me
but it still was a little isolating.
It made it hard to relate
to some of my male peers.
- I've never kissed anybody and it's like,
I really never had an
attraction to anybody.
So how would I know if
I'm gay, straight or bi,
I just don't know yet.
- To me, it's not that
big of a factor like,
I think everyone has a personal journey
of like self discovery.
And for me like, if I am gay,
bi or anything like that like,
I can just see like how I react to that
but I think right now like,
I'm not anything like,
I'm just like neutral.
- Yeah, I feel like what you said earlier
about it being like super simple
between like whether or not
you're straight or you're
just anything else-
- If you're anything else,
that could take a whole lot longer.
Yeah, I could totally see that.
- I feel like it's even
hard to sometimes know
if you're straight like
there's just like this like,
time where you just,
I feel like middle school
and high school is mostly
that time where you just
don't know where you are
and most people find it in college.
So it's just like, I personally
have not defined myself
'cause I don't know myself.
- We have a leadership class
that likes going through
LGBTQ stuff right now.
And I'm thinking you can't really know
if you're gonna be like bi, gay, straight.
Does it really matter?
You don't know until you get like older.
That's really my opinion.
- Yeah, I agree.
I really agree with you.
- I disagree with the stipulation
that you have to be older
to understand.
I'm saying everyone again, has
their own personal journey.
I can look back and see moments
where I was attracted to men
when I was like in kindergarten.
So I think that it really depends
and I think that it
really becomes this thing
of like how we as a
society look at sexuality.
- [Announcer] I've been harassed online.
- It was because of my race.
I'm like originally from
like a really white area
in the south and I was
like the only Black person
in my whole like elementary school.
And this kid somehow like
found like my Instagram
or something and just started
calling me the N-word.
I think it was like eight or nine.
And I think it affected me
'cause like I started like
talking less in my class and
I just felt almost alone.
And when I would try to
tell like some friends I had
at the time, they didn't
really like get it
because a lot of my
friends were also white
and they just thought that
it was like someone playing
a prank.
- I have a similar experience.
I actually have a blog
and in the comment section
someone called me the N-word.
I've never been called it and yeah,
it's beyond what I've expected.
So it just made me feel very
little and like, I don't know,
just like I couldn't do anything and yeah
but cyber bullying, especially,
it hits the same amount
as like if someone was like in
person telling you something.
I'm Suhailah, I'm in eighth grade
and I'm a middle school girl.
Sometimes I'm a little
bit scared of bullies
and I've always been but I'm
learning to stick up to bullies
because I hate when
people just pick on you
for a reason that you can't control.
Sometimes bullies are really
surprised that I'm speaking up
to them because they don't
expect someone like me,
someone who tries to be
kind as much as they can
to stick up to them.
So I always see a surprise
look on their face
but I know that I'm doing the right thing.
For me, it was a different
kind of online harassment.
It was unsolicited pics that
I did not want over Snapchat
and just like a certain person
continuing to send me things
and then like blackmailing me on things.
- When I first got my Instagram like,
the first year I post some photos and then
the first couple minutes I
already started to get harassed
by this random person.
It just really made me uncomfortable
'cause I didn't know who they were
and it was like really creepy.
- Well, I mean, I could
see why five of you
have been harassed like that.
That's over a half of
us that's because just,
you don't know who a person is.
If they just don't upload a
picture, don't choose a name,
anything thing like that, that
of being able to completely
go like incognito, nobody knows you are
so you can't get punished for anything,
that gives these disgusting
people a lot of power
and they wanna abuse it.
- You don't know who picklejam3000 is.
It could be your best friend
or it could be some pedophile online.
You never know and it's just creepy.
It it's like, ooh.
- With me, the person who did that,
I actually like went to school with them.
That was like someone
I saw like every day.
- These people you know
become these completely
different identities as
they begin to just like
turn into the worst versions of themself.
They give into their worst
compulsions because they know
as soon as I'm done, I'll just delete it
and no one can ever know.
You have no accountability.
- [Announcer] I'm excited for the future.
- I think a lot of us hesitated there
because I'm excited if
the future holds change.
But then there are other
futures that are starting
to make themselves known
that I am not excited about.
Like the Texas abortion law,
the Florida Don't Say Gay Bill
that forbids LGBTQ plus
education up to sixth grade
that's probably gonna pass.
It's like these are
futures I do not wanna see
but there are also futures
that I am more than excited about.
- I feel like Gen Z
specifically, we're really
ahead of the game in social change.
And I think that that's gonna carry us far
if we use it to the
best of our capability.
- Yeah I feel like on another note
I'm excited for the
experiences I'm gonna have.
I'm gonna be able to like travel by myself
and there's just so much more I can do
but at the same time it terrifies me
because there's so much I can do.
And like I have so much responsibility.
It's terrifying.
- I wanna make it to college, honestly.
I wanna have the college experience like,
a lot of people I know they're like,
that's where I really found myself.
- I'm excited for the future
to see how I grow as a person
because obviously I'm much
younger than everyone here.
So I'm just excited to see how I grow
and I get to be you guys' age.
I'm also looking forward
to teacher because I do act
so I also wanna see that
grow and I do have a podcast
so I also wanna see that grow.
- Oh my God.
- Hi, my name is Hanadie.
I'm in sixth grade and
I'm a middle school girl.
The podcast is Nine and a
Half podcast because I made it
with when I was nine.
And I basically talk about peer
pressure on a lighter level,
toxic friendships versus
clean friendships.
A lot of things in that matter.
- I am neutral about the future.
Hit me with it, I got it.
Hit me with it but it's like,
I am happy now in my teen years
but then what are my
adult years gonna be like?
So I'm neutral.
Future, come at me but
I'm also happy here.
So that's just how I feel.
- I don't really like to
think about the future
'cause the older you
get, it's thinking like
the more people you could lose.
And I don't really like to think that.
My name is Nino.
I'm in sixth grade and
I'm a middle school boy.
I'm not excited to be in
middle school 'cause I'm aging
and I kind of wanna stay
young but on the other hand,
it's fun to go to middle school
and learn about a lot of new things.
- What a lot of you said,
it's responsibilities,
losing a loved one, being
all alone, all that combined
is why I don't wanna think
about the future specifically.
And essentially, these are
the golden years of our life.
Teenagers, it's perfectly balanced.
- I would disagree that it's perfection
because our bodies are going
through such rapid change.
The way you stand in the world,
you change your personality
what feels like close to
every month to see like how
you can fit in with the world.
But you never seem to fit in
and you always feel alone.
And it's like, that is not perfection.
But I mean, if the future's
gonna be even worse,
I guess I'd rather stay here.
- [Announcer] I believe my
friendships will last forever.
- I have like really close friends,
we've been friends together
like for a long time already.
I remember one of them asked
me to come to like a sleepover
and it was kinda like a
huge thing 'cause like
that was the first time
I ever had any sleepover.
Like those are bonds that were
gonna like hold us together
like forever.
And I know that like a lot of
people I'm friends with now,
I won't be friends with them forever
but I feel like there are people
in my life that will always
gonna be together 'cause
that's my person right there.
Like they've been through
with me like thick and thin.
- And I have this one friend
that I'm allowed to go
to her house and her family
is really sweet to me,
she's really sweet to me,
so I obviously think it'll
last very, very long.
- My current best friend
like the person that I go
to for literally everything,
we went through a really
rough patch this year.
We weren't really talking very
much for a good three months.
And there was a while
where neither of us knew
if we were ever gonna be
friends again 'cause we told
each other that we just
kinda needed a break.
And then about two months ago
she texted me and was like,
you know, I think I have
taken a good amount of space
and I'm ready to be like
close friends again.
And I was like, you
know, I feel the same way
and I feel like we now
know our boundaries better
and I honestly think we're gonna last.
- Like hypothetically speaking,
if my friend who I've known
for really long time moved,
we could still message
hi, new house or whatever.
We'd still be friends because even though
she's not like right in front of my face,
she's right in front of her phone
and I'm right in front of my phone.
So it's like, we're kinda connected.
Therefore we could always
technically be friends forever.
- I'm Olivia, I'm in eighth grade
and I'm a middle school girl.
Some things I love about my
friendships in middle school
is the connection we have.
The fact that we went
from elementary school
to middle school is this big transition.
It's like we see each other growing up.
As we grow, we learn more
amazing things and we just,
our bond grow so much more,
it's just amazing, I love it.
- I remember having like
a bunch of great friends
in like preschool, kindergarten,
and now it's been years
and I don't know where they live,
we're not even in contact anymore.
Like my mom has their phone number
but we haven't been in contact.
So I don't think friendships
like last forever.
They can but like sometimes
you're not in touch or.
- Yeah and like anything can happen.
Like those types of like annoying
things like social media,
things like that can ruin friendships
in the terrible circumstances.
And I hate to be the annoying
one and say, oh you can die,
that's not forever but yeah,
friendships cannot have
anything happen to them.
Some of them last forever but
mine personally, I don't know,
I don't think they will.
- I see friendships that seem
like they are going to last
forever get more and more
dysfunctional as time goes on
until the people separate and never talk
to each other again.
I've gotten stuck in this
cycle of losing friends,
getting bullied, having
everyone like gang up on me
in a beat and I'm the
one person that's alone
and I'm just pessimistic about it now.
I don't think friendships
will last forever
and I don't think that like,
no matter how good your friendship is,
something's gonna screw it up.
- And I also think it's about
taking friendships day by day.
It's not about thinking
about what you're gonna do
in I don't know 10, 20 years.
Like if you're still gonna
be friends or maybe not.
It's just about having
fun with that person,
not thinking about the future too much
because I feel like it's all in the moment
and that's what we should
be focusing on, so.
- Y'all that was,
(group applauding)
you guys are awesome.
Thank you, guys.
(bright upbeat music)